i was just listening to uh the press
conference of the military spokesperson
and basically say out of those who
survive there are actually those
who are in critical condition they are
given the best possible care
some have been flown to zamboanga city
the biggest city closest to hollow
there is a military hospital in holo
which is of course
one of the biggest bases of the
philippine military in the southern
philippines
um you know it is quite a a
nerve-wracking situation for the
military because if we look at the
situation starting this year
this is the third case of an aviation
accident for the philippine air
air force since uh this year they said
that today is a period of mourning that
all flags will be flown at half-mast
but he also said that you know despite
this period of mourning that there's a
full-blown investigation that's underway
investigators have already arrived this
morning
um in hollow um and you know based on
the initial
investigation they said it's unlikely
that it's going to be pilot error
but they said they are determined to
find out what actually
transpired they used to have four c-130
the philippine military
um they are grounding the one that
remains uh in the philippines
and two remain under repair in um in in
portugal
we were also told that you know they're
doing the very best that they can to
inform those
families who some of those bodies have
been identified
that they're going to give them the best
possible honors befitting those who have
died in the line of duty